ouais
l'astuce est d'ajouter durable la
mobilité durable ce n'est pas seulement
une question technologie ce n'est pas
seulement du véhicule électrique versus
du véhicule thermique
c'est un problème sociétal d'abord c'est
un problème de business il faut un
business il faut que le business
s'équilibre fauqué business soit
rentable c'est un problème de sources
d'énergie dans le monde où et l'énergie
dans le monde
ou est ce qu'on la trouve et c'est aussi
un problème de technologie le problème
sociétal sur le plateau de saclay par
exemple on va le trouver en premier ou
vous avez le chalenge campus du futur au
sol plateau de saclay qui est une
recherche d'idées et d'innovations pour
voir comment rendre ce plateau modèle en
termes de mobilité durable et finalement
toutes les écoles du plateau de saclay
toutes les entreprises sont ce plateau
de saclay se sont associés pour réussir
à trouver un nouveau modèle
comment développer un nouveau modèle de
mobilité son plateau de saclay et s'est
trouvé comment ce que développer des
véhicules zéro émission et partout dans
le monde
on développe une application smartphone
qui s'appelle we hope est en fait qui
réinvente l'auto stop et donc on appelle
ça le smart auto stop en fait ça permet
de mettre en relation des piétons qui
sont en train de marcher à rues qui vont
au travail avec les voitures qui leur
fasse devant don qu'ils ont simplement
allumer la plaie visualiser les
véhicules qui vont leur passer dans les
prochaines minutes
et si le trajet de ces véhicules des
intéressés ils sont mis en relation
automatiquement ils peuvent rentrer chez
eux comme ça sur le plateau de saclay on
a lancé grosse expérimentation à grande
échelle sur plus de dix mille salariés
avec cette expérimentation
on a réussi à mettre en relation en
temps réel des gens qui sortaient du
travail qui venait de rater leur bus
avec une des voitures qui leur passaient
devant et qu'ils allaient exactement de
même endroit donc ça permet de rajouter
une composante d'une nouvelle mobilité
qui est le smart auto stop
grâce à notre application et qui va
venir se superposer au réseau de bus
existants l'intérêt du territoire de
paris-saclay c'est qu'on retrouve toutes
les plus grandes écoles qui vont se
retrouver ici les plus grands labos qui
vont se retrouver sur le territoire de
paris saclay la dimension qu'il a
finalement l'étendue du plateau de
saclay que la cohérence du plateau de
saclay on va pouvoir mettre en place une
série de systèmes innovants justement et
là je reviens vraiment sur ce challenge
le campus du futur de saclay qui est
vraiment un challenge passionnant sur
lequel on voit tout le monde est en
train de réfléchir c'est quoi le
la mobilité durable de demain